I think we won the battle because nobody
wants to say they're protectionist
unless there are really wackos
fairness is an important issue in the
United States I mean this is what we
mean by saying that in United States
it's the equality of opportunity not an
outcome that matters so we are a
fairness oriented culture the Europeans
who are actually more stratified they're
more into equality of outcome because
they the ability of people the social
mobility is perceived to be much less
and therefore they want state to
intervene and redistribute what is in
fact going to be an unequal outcome so
they're more into justice and we're more
into fairness
so if you really want to be a
protectionist you've got to go to the to
the political space and say these rented
Japanese or these are Indians whatever
you are actually trading unfairly and
then you've got your case ready-made
people will much more readily give your
protection by saying there's Kaiser
wicked unfair trader so I think it fits
into our cultural milieu much much more
and then outright protection and we won
the battle because nobody wants to say
their protectionist
unless there are really wackos
president actually has made some remarks
there bad beat for the tax adjustment
but not being such a good idea
but he's going to do more than that he's
got to be eloquent he's going to say
this is a crazy thing to do but he's
he's still very cool you know he needs
to lose his temper once in a while look
I'm sure because this is too important
now he knew us is one of the is the
biggest trading nation in the world we
want the rule of law we don't want
retaliation which would be massive
I mean Indian China or not Zyra Zimbabwe
I mean they're not a little they'll come
to you can push around and by god we
don't want to unleash that that kind of
trade war because it could easily be
very hard to control I'm afraid
basically took on arguments which are on
the social side namely you know what
happens as a result of globalization to
women's issues to environment to
democratic governance to poverty in the
poor countries issues which are which I
sometimes call citizen's issues and it
came out basically saying that even on
these were a lot of anti-globalization
critics had or were actually very
skeptical and worried that in fact these
agendas would also be advanced rather
than handicapped by globalization
many people ask me why if I'm for free
trade which I am why I'm against free
trade agreements and I think the the
reason is that free trade agreements are
both free trade and protection there are
two to flip sites together because when
I have free trade just with you I'm
freeing trade with you
but the handicapping of these people are
not members of our fraternity area in
our markets in competing with us is
increased because they have to pay
continue paying the duty is to get into
our markets but we have removed them on
each other so the factor that is
increasing protection against outsiders
and reducing Oh protection in allowing
free trade among ourselves
today with things being produced parts
coming from God knows everywhere first
for you to have to then design which
which product is my partner countries
product rather than outside countries
product becomes completely arbitrary
he's a Canadian car which produced with
Japanese steel chemicals from Germany
etc etc where eighty or ninety percent
of the parts may come from elsewhere is
that a Canadian car no is it really
something else does it qualify for the
zero tariffs you know under NAFTA
he has to step up to the plate and
basically change the ethos in this
country to his understanding that the
United States has profited enormous Lee
the world has been rescued from poverty
not sufficiently but a fair distance in
around the world particularly in India
and China that our own working class is
also profited from international trade
and their worries about you narrator no
good he's got to make an eloquent case
like that
just and he's got to see that this is
something that needs as much attention
as much of his eloquence as the speech
here to make on race after he got into
trouble over you know his his pasture
because he has to make it clear where he
stands and where he's gonna run with the
issue he doesn't have the luxury of most
presidents which is to use a first year
to kind of find your feet on trade he's
got to be out there
you